and also breaking tonight the u.s
supreme court has reinstated a
requirement
in south carolina that absentee voters
provide a witness signature along with
their ballot here with reaction
senate judiciary committee chairman
lindsey graham senator
mitch mcconnell is clear you have been
clear
october 12th the hearings begin
which would lead us to a final vote um
by the end of october am i mistaken on
that timeline
i know i want you to understand we're
going to start the hearings
october the 12th a week from today
safely
if members feel uncomfortable
participating in the hearing in person
they can do it virtually we've done that
a bunch this year
already in the judiciary committee judge
barrett will be there in person
i will be there in person we'll set the
room up for social distance
distancing we're going to move on and as
to senator schumer
if you can't see through this sean
you're just not looking very hard
i don't remember senator schumer asking
the protesters to be
tested before they came to my house and
broke out my window
i don't remember any democrat worried
about testing
during the riots so this is an effort to
deflect
and delay it will not work she will be
confirmed
this year we start on the 12th she gets
reported out of the committee on october
the 22nd
democrats will have plenty of time to
ask her hard relevant questions
if they try to destroy her it will blow
up in her in their face like it did with
kavanaugh
i'm excited about the hearings i want
every american to see
amy barrett and how qualified she is so
around october 26 is that about a safe
date to
look for a final final vote on in the
senate on this
well that's up to sarah mcconnell but
it'd be on the floor october the 22nd
and democrats are trying to destroy her
already
using her religion the democratic party
is trying to take back the house the
senate
beat president uh trump uh they're
having an insane amount of money from
this act blue site raised over 300
million
since justice ginsburg passed my
opponent in south carolina of all places
will raise a hundred million dollars so
if you're out there and you want to
close the gap go to lindsey graham.com
to help me
because i'm going to be fighting for
judge barrett i'm going to be standing
up for conservative judges
and i'm going to help president trump
get this nominee through and on the
court
it will be a tremendous accomplishment
for president trump in our country
to have amy barrett on the supreme court
it's going to happen
i thought you did very well in your
debate over the weekend
congratulations senator thank you thank
you